كشفت ايران عن صاروخ بالستي جديد يبلغ
مداه الفين كيلومتر ويحمل راسا حربيا
تازين 1500 كيلو جرام اكدت انه رساله
لاعدائها بانها مصممه على حمايه امنها
واصدقائها يتزامن هذا مع اعلان اسرائيل
اعتزامها اطلاق مناورات عسكريه الاسبوع
المقبل تحاكي حربا على عده جبهات وصدور
تصريحات ايجابيه من واشنطن وطهران بشان
ملف ايران نووي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما دلاله كشف طهران عن صاروخ بالستي جديد
واعلان اسرائيل عن مناورات تحاكم مواجهات
عسكريه على عده جبهات بعد ايام فقط من
مناورات لحزب الله جنوبيه لبنان
وكيف يمكن ان تتاثر دول المنطقه بحاله
التوتر والتصعيد جراء التبادل رسائل
التهديد بين الجانبين الايراني
والاسرائيلي وعلى اي نحو ستنعكس الانفراج
في الملف النووي على هذا التوتر
واخيرا ما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه
الولايات المتحده لخفض التصعيد في المنطقه
في ضوء تاكيدها المستمر على ضروره حفظ
الامن والاستقرار فيها
[موسيقى]
في خدم توتر في العلاقه مع اسرائيل وتبادل
للتهديدات المعلنه والمبطنه بينهما كشفت
ايران عن صاروخ بالستي جديد يبلغ مداه
2000 كيلومتر ويحمل راسا حربيا تزن الفا
وخمسمائه كيلو جرام ايران التي قالت ان
الصاروخ يصعب استهدافه من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي بسبب سرعته الفائقه اكدت انه رساله
لاعدائها تؤكد تصميمها على الدفاع عن
امنها وعلى مسانده اصدقائها في مواجهه
نظام الهيمة وفق تعبيرها
كشف طهران عن صاروخها يتزامن مع اعلان
اسرائيل عزمها اطلاق مناورات عسكريه
الاسبوع المقبل اكدت انها ستكون شامله
وستحاكي حربا على جبهات عده بما فيها جبهه
سوريا ولبنان وبحسب مراسل الجزيره فان
المناورات التي جاءت غداه اسرائيليه من
ضربه وشيكا على ايران بسبب نشاطها النووي
ستحاكي حالتي الهجوم والدفاع وستشارك فيها
قوه بريه وبحريه وجويه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حاول التقليل من
التهديدات ضد ايران وحزب الله اللبناني
بتاكيده ان التهديدات التي اطلقها كبار
قادته خلال اليومين الماضيين ضدهما لا
تعني شن حرب قريبه على لبنان او ضرب
المنشاه النوويه الايرانيه وذلك وفق ما
ذكرته صحيفه
واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان التدريبات
العسكريه الشامله التي سيطلقها مطلع
الاسبوع المقبل هي مناوره سنويه ومدرجه
ضمن اجنده التدريبات لمحركات حرب متعدده
الجبهات تشمل سوريا ولبنان وغزه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنى من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث في
المركز العربي في واشنطن ومن الدوحات
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني اهلا بكما في ما وراء الخبر ابدا
معك دكتوره فاطمه هذا الكشف من جانب طهران
عن صاروخ باليستي جديد ما الذي يضيفه
وايضا يعني ما قيمته في اطار سباق التسلح
التي تعيشه المنطقه
يمكن فهم ذلك بالنظر الى اهميه البرنامج
الصاروخ الايراني لان واحد من نقاط القوه
الاساسيه بالنسبه لايران وايضا من الملفات
الرد المؤثره جدا هو قدرتها الصاروخيه
ولذلك اضافه هذه القدره الجديده الى
برنامجها الصاروخي هو ايضا يصب في اطار
تعزيز قوه الردع امام التهديدات
الاسرائيليه بصوره
اساسيه لكن هو ايضا ياتي ضمن مقاربه جديده
لايران في المنطقه وهذه المقاربه لها عده
اوجه اهمها الساحه السوريه انا اعتقد بانه
الايران تسعى الى
ايجاد معادله جديده في المواجهه مع
اسرائيل في سوريا ولذلك هي تسعى الى تعزيز
الانظمه الدفاعيه السوريه وهناك حديث في
طهران عن انه
تزويد دمشق بمنظومه وخرداد او الخامس عشر
من خرداد وهي منظومه دفاعيه تشابه 300
روسيه هناك ايضا بعض الرسائل التي خرجت من
الاراضي السوريه مؤخرا بمعنى ان الساحه
السوريه قد تصبح ساعه مواجهه مختلفه مع
اسرائيل هناك ايضا ضمن هذه المقاربه
الجديده رسائل بان الاذرع الخشنه لمحور
المقاومه من الممكن ان تنخرط في حرب
متعدده مع اسرائيل اذا ما تم استهداف
ايران او توجيه ضربه لها طيب اذا هذه
مقاربه جديده من جانب ايران دكتور خليل
ولكن هذا المعطى يتزامن مع عده تحركات
هناك مثلا الكشف المناورات العسكريه التي
تحاكي حرب على عده جبهات والتي تاتي بعد
ايام فقط من المناورات العسكريه لحزب الله
في جنوب لبنان
في الاطار العام هذه التحركات ما الذي
تمثله من خطر وتهديد بالنسبه لامن المنطقه
ككل
انا اعتقد هذه التحديث المتبادله بين
ايران وبين اسرائيل تاتي في السياق اربع
نقاط رئيسيه نكتبها متعلقه باسرائيل
تحديدا وهي
التقارب السعودي الايراني والذي يعلم يبدو
افشل خطه اسرائيليه كانت معده مسبقا فيما
يتعلق بتكوين ما يشبه جبهه سنيه عربيه
اسرائيليه لمواجهه الخطر الايراني كما
طارق اسرائيل هذا التقارب افشل هذا المخطط
شكله واخر الامر الثاني متعلق كما يبدو
وكما دكتوراه فاطمه باعاده تاهيل نظام
الاسد بشار
الاسداح متقدمه ويعزز مساحه وجود ايران في
المنطقه الشماليه فيما يتعلق بالمواجهه مع
اسرائيل وبالتالي يعتبر خطر من وجهه نظري
الامر الثالث المتعلق بما يبدو حتى هذه
اللحظه على الاقل هناك حديث وان كان حديث
الخجولا حول استئناف المفاضلات الايرانيه
بين واشنطن وبين طهران وهذا يعتبر ملف مهم
جدا لاسرائيل خاصه فيما يتعلق
بردع اي محاوله عسكريه في ظل وجود اتفقنا
وايراني الامر الاخر المتعلق ولكن معلق في
رايي الشخصي بلازما الداخليه في اسرائيل
اسرائيل لديها عاده منذ القدم وهي تقوم
بتصدير الازمات الداخليه فيما يتعلق
بالعدو الخارجي خاصه مع حكومه نتنياهو
والتي تستخدم هذه المساله في اكثر من من
من وقت وحدث خلال اخر 15 سنه من عهد
نتنياه وان هناك قفز يعني القيام بحرب او
افتتحال حرب مثلا مع غزه او التوجيه او
التهديد بتوجيه ضربات لايران وبالتالي جزء
منه متعلق بمحاوله لفت الانظار على ازمه
السياسيه الداخليه خاصه في وجود حكومه
يمينا مضطرافيه في اشياء
متعلق بهذا السياق الاقليم والداخلي في
اسرائيل الى حد بعيد طب ايا كانت اهداف
اسرائيل ولكن في النهايه هي رفعت نبره
التهديد هل اعتادت عليها ايران ام انها
اخذتها بجديه اكبر وهل التوضيح الذي قدمته
بان ليس هناك خوف من حرب وشيكا لا على
جنوب لبنان ولا على ايران هل
خففه من اي مخاوف كيف قرات
السؤال له قبل دكتوره فاطمه عفوا انا ظننت
ان السؤال للدكتور نعم بالنسبه لايران لا
هذا ليس تحديدا معتادا ولا ياتي ضمن يعني
الحرب الكلاميه لا هذا تهديد فعلي لانه
اذا اذا نظرنا الى التصاعد الحرب في
المنطقه الرماديه فقد اخذ بعودا تصاعديا
ومن الممكن ان يكون مهيا للوصول الى درجات
اعلى من من التصعيد المساله المهمه الاخرى
ان مستوى التطور في البرنامج النووي
الايراني قد اصبح يعني متقدما جدا والعوده
الى المفاوضات النوويه لم تصبح ليست واقعا
الى الان بمعنى انه الى هذه اللحظه لا
يوجد افق لعوده ايران الى الاتفاق النووي
وحتى بعوده الاتفاق النووي فان ايران لن
تعود الى مستوى التخصيب الذي كان متضمنا
في البرنامج النووي بعد ان وصلت الى هذا
المستوى من التخصيب ولذلك هذه المساله هي
تهديد حقيقي قبل فتره اجرت اسرائيل منورات
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وصفت بانها
الاولى في تاريخ العلاقه بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا تضمنت
ما يشبه مشابهه لحرب تقليديه مع مع ايران
لذلك فهذه ليست مجرد مناورات سنويه كما ان
مستوى
مستوى الحراك في الاقليم اي ينبغي ايضا
بان الامور تتجه الى نوع من من التصعيد
المساله التي اشار اليها الدكتور خليل هي
بمثابه وكانه تم صب ما على النار التي
كانت تحاول اسرائيل ان ان تشعلها في في
المنطقه بمعنى ان تحاول ان تقدم نفسها
انها خيار في مواجهه اسرائيل ولذلك فان
المساله مهمه جدا على هذا الصعيد هي ان
دول المنطقه في الاقليم تحتاج بالفعل الى
نوع من ايجاد نظام امن اقليمي مشترك يضمن
مصالح دول هذه المنطقه وامنها حتى وان وجد
نوع من المواجهه مع اسرائيل طيب هناك امر
لافت غداه كشف موقع اكسيوس عن محادثات
محتمله الاسبوع القادم بشان ملف ايران
النووي تستضيفها واشنطن ويشارك فيها
مستشار الامن القومي ووزير شؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليان اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الهيان
عما وصفه بانه تقدم جيد في مفاوضات احياء
الاتفاق النووي طبعا تصريحات عبد الله
سبقتها تاكيدات امريكيه لامكانيه التوصل
الى حل دبلوماسي بشان ملف ايران النووي
اذا اريد ان اسالك دكتور خليل عن هذه
النقطه تحديدا هل فعلا
يمكن
الحديث عن تحذير جدي عندما يتحدث رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن ضربه وشيكه على
ايران
بسبب نشاطها النووي ويؤكد انها تقدمت
بتخصيب اليورانيوم على نحو غير مسبوق تاتي
هذه التصريحات كيف نفهمه
قد يعطيها ذلك مساحه بشكل او باخر القيام
بطلبات ضد ايران لكن بشكل عام من الصعب
جدا توقع حدوث ضربات ايرانيه عفوا
اسرائيليه لايران بدون وجود وجود ضوء اخضر
امريكي وموافقه ايضا اوروبيه وقد قرانا في
الاخبار على مدار الثلاث شهور ان هناك
بالفعل جولات قام بها نتنياهو وهناك رسائل
متبادله مع الدول الاوروبيه خاصه المانيا
وفرنسا وبريطانيا تم اطلاعهم على وجود
مخطط ما وجود خطط ما من اجل تجديد ضربات
عسكريه النوويه الايرانيه لكن بشكل او
باخر اعتقد ان الصعب في هذه المرحله على
الاقل وجود يعني موافقه امريكيه على
القيامه يعتبر تحول خطير جدا قد يفتح حرب
اقليميه من الصعب جدا توقع نتائجها على
جميع الاطراف اذن الدكتوره فاطمه تعتبرين
ان هذا الحديث لوزير الخارجيه وايضا تاكيد
واشنطن يعني امكانيه تقدم حقيقي في ملف
المفاوضات يصب ماء بارد على التهديدات
والتحذيرات الاسرائيليه
نعم هو دائما كانت ايران تتبع هذه
الاستراتيجيه بانه هي وان كانت كانت تصل
التفاوض الى مرحله التجميد لكنها لم يحدث
ان انسحبت من المفاوضات بصوره نهائيه
بمعنى انها دائما كانت تترك باب التفاوض
مفتوح
والمساله المهمه الاخرى المرتبطه بمساله
التفاوض انه في الاشهر الماضيه
انتهجت ايران سياسه تقوم على نزع فتيل
التوتر مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
خاصه وانه الوكاله الدوليه كانت واحد من
المداخل للتصعيد فيما يتعلق بالبرنامج
النووي الايراني وربما كانت المشكله مع
الوكاله هي التي اعاقت سابقا الوصول الى
كانت واحده من المواضيع التي عاقت الوصول
الى
اتفاق باحياء الاتفاق النووي الايراني لكن
انا ما اظنه انه
السعي الى التفاوض المباشر مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو قرار لم ينضج في
طهران الى اليوم واذا حدث ذلك انا اعتقد
انه يتجه الى نوع التفاوض على اتفاق جديد
ولذلك فهذا سياخذ
حيزا زمنيا كبيرا جدا حتى لو لم يكن ناضجا
بما يكفي دكتور خليل ولكن واضح ان هناك
حاجه للتعبير عن ذلك
والسؤال كيف سينعكس هذا سواء حتى بالتعبير
عنه فقط واذا ما حصل انفراج حقيقي في
الملف كيف سينعكس على التوتر في المنطقه
ككل
انا اعتقد هناك حاجه لخفض تصعيد في
المنطقه العربيه اي تقدم في ملف النووي
الايراني هو بالتاكيد سينعكس ايجابيا على
المنطقه العربيه هناك على مدار اخر كم
اسبوع هناك حاله تبريد ملفات الساخنه في
المنطقه العربيه مثلا ملف اليمني هناك
تبريد له هناك شبه اتفاق على انهاء الحرب
والدخول في مفاوضات من اجل وقف هذه الحرب
الامر الثاني متعلق بالملف السوري هناك
اعاده التطبيع مع الاسد وان كان طبعا هذا
ايضا للملف المتعلق بالعلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه هناك عدم ملف متعلق حتى هذه
لحظه على الاقل هناك مؤشرات على وجود
احتمال تطبيع لقد بين القاهره وبين طهران
وبالتالي هناك ملفات يتم تبريدها بشكل او
باخر وبالتالي اذا تم هناك اتفاق نووي
ايراني مع الغرب خاصه مع واشنطن هذا ينعكس
طبعا ايجابا على المنطقه العربيه خاصه في
ظل وجودها تهديد الاسرائيلي المتواصل
باتجاه طهران ليس مصاحب الدول العربيه على
الاطلاق الخليج العربي وجود مواجهه عسكريه
مع اسرائيل ينادي اعتبر يعني تحدي
استراتيج كبير جدا هذه المنطقه التي تقع
في يعني في القلب بين هذين هذين القوتين
النوايتين او لحد ما القوه المؤثره جدا في
في طهران فيما يتعلق بالتطوير قدرات نوويه
وطبعا قوه نوويه عند اسرائيل وبالتالي من
الصعب جدا وجود توتر ده ان تتوقع تتوقف
العواقف فقط عند هدان الدولتين بالفعل
الدول العربيه في منتصف وبالتالي اي حرب
اقليميه اي تدخل عسكري طبعا عسكري ايرانيه
اسرائيليه للايران قد تؤثر بالسلب طبعا في
المنطقه العربيه طيب وفي النهايه الى ان
يحصل تقدم حقيقي دكتوراه فاطمه نبقى مع
هذه التصريحات
بعضها صريح بعضها خفي ولكن تنبئ بتوتر الى
اي حد يمكن ان ينعكس على دول المنطقه ما
الذي تملكه دول المنطقه يعني ان تقدموا ان
تفعلوا من اجل ربما تغيير الوضع
كما اشرت انه مساله الحوار الدائره الان
في الاقليم هي مساله في غايه الاهميه
والخطوه الايرانيه السعوديه هي ايضا خطوه
مهمه جدا اذا تحول هذا الاتفاق الى خطوات
عمليه فهذه مساله ستؤدي الى نوع من
الضمانات الامنيه في المنطقه لكن انا
اتمنى ان يقود ذلك الى نوع من بناء نظام
امن اقليمي تشترك مشترك لدول المنطقه بحيث
يوجد مجموعه من المص التي يتم ضمانها من
خلال هذا
النموذج الامني وهو مساله تحتاج الى خطوات
الى قرارات الى نوع من القرار السياسي
الجريء في المنطقه ما حدث من تطور في
الموضوع الايراني السعودي ربما يكون هو
خطوه اولى على هذا الصعيد هذا بالنسبه
لدول المنطقه اما بالنسبه وهنا اسالك
دكتور خليل واعود لتصريحات ادلى بها
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون
الاقليميه
المتحدث الاقليمي قال للجزيره ان واشنطن
تريد ان ترى هذه المنطقه امنه ومستقره
والسؤال هو من دور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه
واشنطن في هذا الاطار من اجل تحقيق هذا
الهدف الذي لطالما اعلنت عنه
انا اعتقد الخطوه الرئيسيه متعلقه بوقف كل
استرداد الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق سواء في
العلاقه مع الفلسطينيين وهذا يعتبر ملف
مهم جدا وهذا يعتبر ايضا الحديث عنه من
خلال حديث المسؤول الاسرائيلي خلال
الماضيه فيما يتعلق بتوحيد الساحاتهم من
وجود حرب من الشمال ومن الجنوب عليهم سواء
كان من غزه والضفه الغربيه وجنوب لبنان ثم
سوريا وبالتالي اي ضغط امريكي يعتبر ضغط
جيد لحد بعيد هناك سؤال كبير جدا حول
امكانيه القيام بذلك اعتقد انه هذه
المرحله صعب جدا الصوره العامه عن اداره
بايدن هي اداره مهتزه اداره ضعيفه مشغوله
بشكل ملفات اخرى كما قلت قبل قليل ملف
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ملف التنافس
مع الصين وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
على ما يبدو استغلال اسرائيل لهذه المساله
وهناك الضغط اسرائيلي من اجل التخريب اي
محاولات للتواصل بين ايران وبين واشنطن
فيما يتعلق بملف النووي وبالتالي اذا كانت
واشنطن جده بالفعل في وقف التصعيد يجب
عليها ان تلج الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق
بفلسطينيين فيما يتعلق بتهديد ايران
وبالتالي الدخول في اط ار من
المفردات الجديه او المتعلقه في النوى
الايراني وبالتالي سحب فتيل اي محاوله
لاشعال حرب اقليميه قد تاتي بالكوارث على
الجميع ماذا طهران كيف ترى الدور الامريكي
هنا دكتوره فاطمه
في منسوب كبير من عدم الثقه بين ايران
واشنطن ولذلك هذا العوده للتفاوض لا تعني
ان هناك يعني نشوء صفحه جديده او فتح صفحه
جديده من العلاقه بين طهران وواشن لكن كما
قلت هو خيار التوفى لم يغلق في اي وقت من
الاوقات بالنسبه لطهران وطهران تريد اغلاق
هذا الملف الذي يشكل
تحديدا بالنسبه لها لكن على صعيد العلاقه
سيبقى التوتر حاصلا مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اشكرك جزيلا دكتوره فاطمه
الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره
للدراسات والخبيره في الشان الايراني
وشكرا جزيلا لضيفنا من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث في المركز
العربي في واشنطن
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى ان
نلتقي في حلقه جديده لكم اطيب تحيه فيما
له
[موسيقى]